in Australia there are 52 weeks in a
year does anyone know how many of those
weeks in our country you're allowed to
go on leave but still be paid really bet
again
Shirley says I think what it is in the
US but in Australia it's actually full I
see you're learning something again yeah
stand track with me there's lots of
different kinds of it what the different
kinds of ways okay it's important that
you know down that's four week no but
that's actually a very significant
number I'll explain in a second that's
four weeks of annually but every year
you get a new four week so employers
will actually say yes you can bank that
up as much as you'd like maybe you are
you don't take annually first a three
year that means you've got how many
weeks back doc well twelve weeks and
then you're like I'm not even going to
Europe for a few years okay so people
often Bank is up but number one often
you can't do that because you know you
just need a break right maybe you need
to know like high off you go to his
house renovate or something like that
and you need to be around your house
you're going to have to use some left
and lovely often employers actually want
you to take leave does anyone know why
because we started it off
yeah that's right so remember I said you
might save up all of this that you might
Bank it up right 12 weeks nothing
unusual you might be working for a
really long time at half-life in fact if
you guys have seen I know how to clean
it there's different kinds of leaching
yep you can be at a company for so long
that you've got like a whole years worth
of annual leave you can just still be
there you'll get paid but you're not
there for a whole year now the company
doesn't like that understandably because
I mean they're still paying you money
you're never coming back but they can
hire a replacement of you why not
because you're still one of their
employees so they're like great you know
hairiness studies what's all of it
whatever you know you still here I can't
actually hire someone to place in or any
of you so this is just one of these is
what actually will tell you take me
thinking now there's a bit of a there's
a bit of a tradition that it's really
important to get under here's why I put
it as a four weeks before millennium
this is important that you called
league-leading leave buddy now this is a
bit little rehash talk with you I won't
give you all the details can we focus
again if they come and they come in
leave loading is based on this simple
idea when you're early
let's just achieve every single year you
take you four weeks and you go on a
holiday or something like that for those
who have been on holidays and have
watched carefully do you spend less
money when you're at holidays or more
money more usually a lot more like
you're out you don't home see your
family what's cooking you're going on
like the paralyzed and what-have-you
so you spend more money that means you
want more income so what they do is they
say look during that time when you're
only during those four weeks we will pay
you an extra
seventeen and a half percent it's a very
strange number
the basically country to start or with
negotiations between trade unions and
employers of governmental are three very
box
what should we send so what this means
is a little bit like it's time to have
double posting right let's actually put
the economy let's suppose you burn a
cool $100,000 on a visual style guy
okay so let's just suppose that what it
says on your contract now what they'll
do is they'll say okay so four weeks in
the deal when you go on annual leave you
actually don't get paid to regular you
get paid seventeen a half percent extra
so we need to work this out
a hundred thousand dollars for us Origen
vs. two weeks because this is four weeks
worth of snot so how do I work out how
much of this immediate paid in four
weeks
okay the first thing we're going to do
is I'm going to divide by six to one
yeah one time I won't talk about this in
second one there are different rules
around salary and wages we'll talk about
in a minute that means sometimes we
don't use the another picture - because
52 times seven is not in fact 365 days
anyone
just look at the numbers it's research
before you can know it's 364 people 7
times 2 is going to be 14
right so it's clearly not going to end
in apply it before it's not a full
number of weeks right if you're going to
go all the way to 356 today you'd say 50
should put one in okay now this course
is not about remembering which ones it's
supposed to be if you're being asked to
do some kind of calculations here and it
matters whether it's 52 or 52 / when it
will tell you and you don't get told you
just write just like I have don't go
straight to the answer like the number
you're / which 52 point one eight write
that down so I can see now this is the
whole year 52 weeks in here so this is
how many weeks of pay whatever summer is
this number is one we can play so I
asked you what for we prepare always the
same sign speedily yeah when you spawn
again never too soon
I'll take morning
please this is for wintertime can you
tell me what my single in 72 okay this
is what pointing out by the way I'm
assuming this trails off this goes to
get water for prices after this because
we're dealing with money you shouldn't
need to be told two decimal places like
linear simple so this is and we might
label it a touch this is the normal four
weeks of pay for what they'll fees
okay we're going to pay you this extra
it leaves loading it's exactly 17 a half
percent of that okay so let me quickly
work that out seventeen and a half
percent of that seven ounces and 19 of
us like that you actually have a percent
button on your calculator I think it's
worth it for you
the practice can very suggestible that
was what one of the things in the first
question was about so what is this is a
decimal 0 n so you can either type in 17
and 1/2 percent time or you can type
zero point one seven five times I
clearly protection sponsor what do you
get one
okay so that there is the woody more
weeks of sentient life okay so if you
wanted to off while I'm on line or we
could leave how much am I actually going
to pay they want you to do is take these
two numbers and as and then you're going
to give yourself down the book it is
elegant